oh when I was a kid that was my dream  job gentlemen spy I always felt the Old  Bond films are only as good as the  villain was a child I rather fancied a  future as a colorful megalomaniac what a  shame we both had to grow up see Cox is  on the list what about Reed and Bryson  well that's uh that's an interesting  part of the story I found obituaries for  both radon ransom of the three shooters  you're the only one left I need you to  get there first and what are the names  Michael and Jimmy common  we're right you want the job or not  Conlon I'll kill that mother free  come with me  no one else is gonna die because it Mia  you know I'm just one person I'm not  worth you are acquitted you more  affected to me he have to promise me  that you're not gonna leave I want you  to promise me that you want